so today we're going to learn the basics
of three different cloud provider
and Microsoft so before I start sure to
let you know that you don't have to
frantically take notes or anything all
the github repositories this
presentation all the notes are on my
website so that's all you need to
remember it I'll have it up on a bunch
of different slides so why do I want to
give this talk being a self heart
developer it means your education is
kind of ad-hoc most of the things I
learned were when I needed a project and
then I had to Google how to do it when I
was working more and more in the cloud I
realized most people aren't going to
have the chance to work with different
cloud providers changing cloud providers
can be very difficult and not worth a
company's time and if you do get to
choose a provider on the next job it's
much easier to go with the one you're
familiar with because despite all the
documentation and demos cloud services
have a steep learning curve they all
accomplish similar tasks but with
different terminology and different
design philosophies so after today I
hope you'll have the knowledge and
confidence to start creating your own
projects especially if you haven't done
anything with the club yet and before we
dive into the tech I want to keep you in
mind of my motto for all of my Tech
Talks
I want you to learn how to use these
tools so you can do less but accomplish
more let's make something fun but not
work too hard so what is service I like
this quote from AWS service computing
allows you to build and run applications
and services without thinking about
service they don't require you to
provision scale and manage any servers
you can build them for nearly any type
of application or back-end service and
everything required to run and scale
your application with high availability
is handled for you so this is also often
called function as a service you
provided business logic and they take
care of everything else
so there are servers you just don't have
to worry about them
surveillance works best as small
self-contained micro services each
service does exactly one thing so you
don't think create complex interactions
in each one
instead they talk to each other to
create larger features as an example
let's talk about an e-commerce site like
Amazon and it's checkout page when a
customer is trying to check out there
are numerous questions that need to be
answered to provide a checkout service
here I'm answering questions like are
the items available what warehouse are
they in to check shipping speed are
there promo codes what payment methods
are available do they have a gift card
things like that but kind of separating
them out into different services it
means only the service needed is running
at any given time and remember with a
service at the service spins itself up
when needed and then it spins itself
down or not so if you don't have a lot
of people using the service it you're
not getting charged for it because it's
not being used and if millions of people
are using your service then it
automatically scales so it allows for
independence and the services can do
anything as long as the input and output
stays the same when looking at this
chart it should remind you of relational
tables or endpoints in a restful api so
keeping that process in mind I wanted to
create a template that can be used to
make all of these services I want an MP
and pin point that allows you to add
data to persistent storage get that data
edit that data and delete that data a
classic crud architecture I want to be
able to test that endpoint deploy
updates and have it secured I want my
template to define all the services I
use so they all get destroyed
I can easily spit up everything again
when you're working with cell providers
there's basically three ways to
provision your infrastructure you can do
it in the console so just clicking
around on the UI you can do it via
command line or you can do it via
configuration file I really wanted to do
a configuration file because it's the
most it has that history and it's the
mote the easiest to spin up again you'll
also remember the commands that you ran
before you just have one configuration
file so it's kind of it goes from
easiest
the hardest in terms of how you use it
but it goes from worse to better
basically
so here's the following questions I
would answer about each of the cloud
providers and not only wanted to answer
them but then test it myself and save it
in the repo I miss at the site so not to
discourage you but my first lesson with
all these providers is that they were
way harder than they looked sending up a
quick example in that UI is fairly
straightforward and then making it in
the command line is a little harder but
so but even then it doesn't always work
setting up an app in a sustainable way
so they can be production ready it was
much more difficult there are a myriad
of options on everything you do error
messaging can be obtuse and hopefully
you're a little sympathetic as engineers
that has tried to write an error message
for someone understand but I'm telling
you this so you do preserve persevere
there's a steep learning curve but
sustaining and scaling the system makes
it worth it but I'll go over today won't
give you all the answers but hopefully
it'll give you that step up so you don't
run into all the walls that I did over
and over again so let's start with the
services what are each of the services
needed to create my Mercury service how
do they work how do they play nicely
with each other I asked myself what was
the easiest way to store an item with an
attribute for each service what's this
service tool to access that data and how
do I create an endpoint of that service
so this is what I decided on for AWS
it's all separate so it's API gateway
lambda and dynamodb API gateway is a
dedicated service creating a wrap
routing if you know python is like flask
or django just the web framework lambda
is the function where it parses the
requests and accesses the database be an
sdk so it's just all your code and then
dynamodb is a non-relational document
storage I chose this database because
it's the best integrated with the
service services on AWS if you're used
to sequel and haven't worked with a non
sequel database like MongoDB you have to
be careful because you can quickly get
messy if you don't control the input you
should think of
databases like this is more like a
dictionary a Python or a hash you have
an object with a key and whatever values
you want I use it here because it's fast
and easy to set up and it tends to not
have too much complexity with one of
these small tests architectures it
doesn't need foreign keys if we stop
touching any other tables so I worked on
I tried setting up my sequel but it
requires a whole slew of services that's
when you need your V pcs and your
security groups and it's just a huge
pain in the butt and it wasn't worth it
when I just need to store a single table
for a sure I use HTTP tricker as your
function and cosmos DB you'll notice as
as your name dysfunction to represent
what it is literally a function its
points in its favor I also want to point
out the entry point to a function is not
another service there's no separate API
gateway for Azure and you'll see for
Google as well so instead as your has
this concept called trigger and bindings
a trigger is anything they can call a
function in this case we're gonna use an
HTTP trigger which will handle the
routing you can also trigger with other
services like a file landing and storage
or a row changing a database or a
logline
binding is the output of a function in
this case the binding output is gonna be
cosmos DB the data storage flexible and
holds a variety of collections so I use
it as a table and then access my data
via sequel queries because that's what I
don't use I chose cosmos DB because it's
built in recommended servers for
functions so I hope you're starting
notice a trend here it's like whatever
they said to use is what I use because
that's what they had the most
documentation on for cloud they have
exact same HTTP sugar cloud functions
and then their database with cloud
firestore it's like Google and Azure in
a meeting and both decided that the
functions are called functions AWS
didn't join that meeting they also got a
point for that so they get negative
points for the biggest problem with
Google which was the combination of
documentation so there's something
called App Engine and cloud function and
it's super confusing so when you search
for one sometimes you'll get
documentation for the other and I just
want to point that out in case you're
looking for something and you're like
this doesn't look like what I was just
writing you
probably accidentally brought up at
function instead of cloud functions App
Engine instead of cloud for students
they do some more things but the cloud
functions is kind of that pure server
list and App Engine is a little more
complicated so if I what I liked about
Google is that it uses flask so if you
already know Python you're already using
flask it's great you can just upload
your function as is the testing was
really easy because of that it's the
routing is tied to the programming
language you use unlike Azure or AWS
with a routing is kind of separate but
in practice that really didn't make a
difference there's actually just kind of
nice because I knew how flash worked
already so if you're anything like me
you want a code as soon as possible
you're so excited to solve that problem
you just want to get in write your
business logic and get out so I wanted
to test each provider and how fast I was
writing code a nice feature of all three
of the providers is the ability to try
things out in the UI before you even
have to create your github repository
this is the best way to start but please
don't end there so you can see how the
service and connect get things launched
play around without having to worry
about syntax and it's definitely
possible don't make an entire project
that way but you're not using source
control or IDs that make collaboration
possible so I mean my fresh github
repository and got started for AWS I use
this tool called Sam Sam is a multi-use
open-source tool for this section doing
Sam initialized does the initial
directory set up including a sample
HelloWorld function includes a readme
that doubles as the tutorial for the set
up I was able to go into this app that
py file and start working I only started
running into trouble when I had to add a
library like I was like oh I like simple
JSON rather than the built in JSON
library it was way more difficult than
you'd expect for authentication to my
AWS account I set up a config file on a
profile because I had multiple aw counts
on my computer and that's all in the
readme
and then I set up all the secret
configurations as environment variables
it wasn't built-in so I had to handle
the storing and deploying of the
environment variables myself which is
pain yeah one initiative step is that I
had to confirm my identity via a phone
call which took a few hours to get to me
so I was like super confused why like
nothing worked for a couple hours and
then I like gave up and they called me
and then everything something worked
again like oh maybe you should have said
hey we're waiting to confirm your
identity but it's like one of those
things that no one tells you and then it
used to be very frustrated so just look
out for that if you don't already have
an AWS account for Azure they have
something called fu NC or funk it's kind
of an all-purpose tool like Sam that has
an it says of everything it's
straightforward and walks you through
setting up your first project one
warning is that all the installations
take a long time so when I was working
on this I was like okay I have an hour
to work on this and it took like two
hours to install everything so I did
give up for the day so I use this
tutorial called eight creating HTTP
triggered function and Azure and
everything worked great I really love
the initialization on here it handled
all the passwords stored on my computer
I didn't have to handle any of that it
just really set up very nicely so the
one it gave me my sample function the
actual Python looked very strange
because of some formatting it kind of
seemed more like Java I was like did I
accidentally hit Java inside of Python
but once you kind of understand the
trigger binding dynamic of in and out it
starts to make more sense and then all
the local settings are handled really
well like I didn't have to think about
it like gave me a file and when I said
deploy it deployed it and I didn't have
to worry about how I was gonna you know
set that up and there's so many
different ways to setup environmental
function of iron mental variables it was
nice that it handled it for me so for
Google it wasn't a single tool that got
up me up and running they didn't have
anything that was just like initialize a
new project it said I kind of cobbled
together a bunch of tutorials I started
with it in the UI and then I downloaded
the function to see what it look like
did not include a configuration file so
I was very confused
but it actually didn't need it which is
you know why is confusing so in the
meantime they had a Python samples
repository which was actually really
great so I had like a bunch of different
functions the other people already
written and I was able to pull that in
and test it and instead of you know I'll
talk about this more about in testing
but I didn't have to like launch a local
instance of it it was just a flat flask
app so I just got to test my functions
that way and then for authentication you
just set up a key download a file and
for environmental settings it's similar
to AWS where it goes into a config file
and you store it in their version of a
secure key viola pair so AWS it's called
secrets manager and at Google it's
called NDB and it's all unencrypted and
you just have to be careful not to put
it in your github repo
so I'm keep hammering on this but in any
cloud service you want to
programmatically describe the
infrastructure as much as possible
this means the configuration for the app
is right now and can be stored in
version control and you can see what's
happening and someone isn't just going
in and deleting a database and no one
knows how they did that so for example
Amazon uses a tool called cloud
formation cloud formation reads either
Gamal or JSON and in that file you can
say I'm gonna make a table call it this
give it these settings have this index
and if you want to add or change
something about that setup you want to
put it in that configuration file it
allows for multiple environments
emergency recovery things like that it's
a professional level project you'll want
at least one staging environment testing
is out before you release the production
and having these configurations files
made environmental setup very easy I
don't know if you've if you've ever
provisioned multiple environments on AWS
it can be kind of a pain because you
have to just like figure out all the
settings and everything like that with
server list
it was just like giving it give me any
more for texture here's the new name of
it so like I was having fun with it
making a bunch of different environments
my names and animal names and just going
to town just to see if it worked and it
came up in a few minutes it was awesome
is he able to run it and then bring it
down
um so I talked a little bit about Sam
and CloudFormation and I want to talk
about how they combine so basically Sam
is a way of making CloudFormation easier
so cloud formation is that yeah mo or
Jason file but it can be very verbose
Sam basically takes that and makes
shortcuts for it so I like to start with
a Sam yamo file and write it out in that
syntax and then use Sam to convert it to
cloud formation just because it's easy
to write but they're very tightly
coupled so if you want to use something
in Amazon that's not covered by Sam you
just put the cloud formation syntax
right into your llamo so for example I
wanted to use secrets manager to store
an API key and Sam doesn't have the
capability for it so I just looked up
the cloud formation syntax put it into
that Sam file and when Sam converts to
the cloud formation it right it knows oh
this is already in cloud formation
syntax let's just push it through so
it's a nice way to start with the Sam
that way it's kind of like eases you
into how to set it up and then you can
add complexity later on one thing to
make sure of that I actually learned
recently is that when you're building
stuff with cloud formation stacks on
Amazon that you have to build everything
in your configuration so it doesn't
recognize services you build outside of
it so say you built a table manually
with the command line and then you want
to add it to your service this the
CloudFormation template it won't be able
to connect it to it won't be able to
it'll just say oh this tables already
created I'm confused I'm just gonna
crash but if you delete that table and
then say remake it in the Yama file
it'll already know it's there and then
every time you do an update it can't it
knows it's there so it's just kind of
remember that don't make things outside
of your configuration cuz then I guess
lost so for an azure function you don't
need any dedicated tool like Sam instead
you just have a JSON file when you
initialize it's created for you with
cheapy trigger in and then that HTTP
trigger binding out so all I added in
was the Cosmo TV binding so my data goes
in there when I post it and then that
other file called local settings and
then you can add settings in there and
it'll be able to find it and then you
just add a flag into the Floyd to make
sure hey always deploy my setting so
it's really straightforward so for the
Google function there was no config file
which was like since it was a third
cloud provider I was like yeah I was so
expecting this configuration file and if
you see any references and documentation
to act that yeah mo that is for another
service that is for App Engine and the
only connection or another tool other
tools is basically through the SDK
inside the function so if you want to
access a database you don't say you know
doing the configuration you say access
it in the function and then if you need
something more complex than what's
provided that's when you want to move to
App Engine but the simple way is to just
do it in the watcher so one feature all
these providers have in common is open
API you might know it as swag it's
basically standard for describing
restful api and that's what you'll want
to use the designer API it's like the
only thing they all do the same and it's
awesome so if you wanted to change over
you can just take your API to any of
those services
it's especially crucial to define your
API for the databases I picked it
because it helps with things like
payload validation otherwise everything
will just throw into a database you make
you know fields on the fly it won't it
won't validate it at all so it's good
announcer now that I know where the code
wood was gonna go I want to do some
testing especially when I'm working with
these brand new tools standing up tests
helps me learn how to use them and I use
Python debugger tool to stop the code
and evaluate the different scenarios on
the spot which was really nice so an AWS
and Azure the unit tests were all fairly
similar to other Python projects for any
outside calls like calls the database I
mocked it because you don't want your
test calling outside services otherwise
it's not a unit test and it can me it
doesn't look like it's doing it's like
kind of like dangerous it doesn't let
you know like hey I'm calling a database
in AWS when you're running this unit
test so just be careful when you're
running it kind of check everything and
make sure you've mocked any outside
calls because you also could be spending
money accidentally just like a very
common cloud provider problem and it
could also get confusing if you have
multiple people calling the same
database and running these tests they
don't know what's happening for Amazon I
was able to get example payloads from
the console and it's all in the the
lambda console for Azure I just kind of
played around the functions until I
figured out how to mock a request from
that HTTP end to make sure my requests
are all coming in correctly well one of
the nice things too about being able to
set up environments so easily is that if
you want to do that full integration
test and I think I talked about this a
little more oh it's in my next slide is
that the way the easiest way to do it is
to just spin up a new environment and
then start hitting those endpoints with
something like postman or curl and then
you just delete that environment like
you're done with it it's just a really
nice way of spinning things up quickly
and testing testing the way it is in
production I'm sure many of you have
experienced this where your development
environment is different than production
so things work fine and then you get to
production it doesn't work at all
so that's really one of the nicer
features at being able to spin up all
these random environments you can test
as much as you want see so you can do
some local testing you kind of like spin
up fake environments on your machine but
it's not exactly right so it's kind of
suffers from that problem but it's a
good first start you can do it with the
Sam and the function with AWS and Azure
one library I really liked that I always
recommend in Python is VCR so VCR you
can test your payloads and it will
record it and you can save it in your
repo and it's just like a really nice
like side tool that I like to use I want
to throw that out there
so for Google it's the same as any flask
app I use what I found on the repo I was
able create unit and integration tests
that use PI tests and it was just really
nice it was one of the nice features of
them being really supportive of kind of
the open source frameworks so one thing
to note is that all of them suffered
from like really poor error messaging
while doing tests to one degree another
Amazon had my favorite one where just
said times out without telling you what
took so long or why it would you know
something's not connected correctly oh
the errors times out all right well that
doesn't make sense
but eventually I kind of got them all to
go through you kind of just have to
persevere and that's one of the you know
I just want to push you through like
this is it's all a pain but you'll get
there and I've given this talk it and
I've told people who work there so maybe
one day they'll improve their messaging
so once you got your code working and
tested it's time to deploy I I always
deployed manually first just to make
sure it works I'm an Amazon as you're
using those same tools
I let salmon Franck tip package deploy
the applications let's see for Amazon I
want to let you know that you know
you're deploying that cloud formation
stock stack and that you're not gonna
get it right the first time or the fifth
time or the 20th time but you'll
eventually figure out what the syntax is
for automated deploy the recommended
tools is called code pipeline and github
when I set those up it was actually
pretty cool I just connected my github
repository and I was able to say every
time I deploy a master branch reload the
environment which was nice
I'm going a little faster she's starting
to run out of time for a sure you deploy
using that function app so one warning
here is that logging isn't always
necessarily turned on which you also be
super confusing so for a sure it's
called application insights so just make
sure to go the console and turn it on I
like to think of cloud providers as
Spirit Airlines like they don't turn
or charge you for anything without you
telling them but then they told you for
everything so just be careful to make
sure to turn it on and one thing with
the Azure SDKs I had some problem but I
realize is because they're Python is in
beta mode and I wasn't gonna learn a new
language for this test so just keep that
in mind when you're working with it if
you're working with python which i think
is very hopefully it's popular language
here and then they have a tool called
azure devops it's similar in style to
Amazon you connect your bridge with
github and you have this pipeline that
every time you hit the branch it
automatically updates things which is
pretty cool
one thing you have to keep in mind is
that if you keep you have to make
something called a pipeline and release
that really confused me when I started
let's see oh and the pipeline is where
you put things like the pie shop Python
version your test your code quality
tasks like flake and pie tests and then
the release actually deploys it so
Google the only thing that's different
is that you have to mirror your code in
their repository to get everything to go
up but it's this actually was the
fastest deploy process I had for me it
was basically like I was missing one
permission and that's took me forever to
figure out but then after that
everything worked very smoothly so it
actually they had actually the best
error message which was error with this
run this command to fix this error and I
was so excited until I ran the command
to fix the error and then it gave me a
syntax error and I was like oh but and
then she figured out in the console was
a memory of the contact so see ya after
all my issues with that the automated
deploy and Google's great I'm gonna talk
real quick about security so as of now
I've been kind of building an API that
anyone can access if you had the right
you know endpoint you can access API but
you don't want to whether it's a public
API or a bunch of internal services you
want to control who access it and when
and you don't want to allow and
access even from internal services
because of one service breaks it can you
know cascade and bring everyone else
down so it's also helpful for compliance
so if you deal with something like PCI
or healthcare compliance or credit cards
you can limit that data access between
them and then finally you want to limit
developer access to change the
infrastructure because the engineers are
just press buttons and will be like oh
this is fine for Amazon and all the
other ones too
they have something called I am identity
access management
I believe it stands for it is so
confusing because it's so granular every
little thing you could do in the
services you can't need a permission for
so at first it just seems like a huge
headache cuz you're like oh I just want
this lambda to talk to this database and
why do I need 17 permissions but the
more you do it more you get used to it
basically I do this process of I try to
run something it doesn't work it says
I'm missing a permission I add that
permission I try to run it again and
then kind of repeat that process over
and over again until I actually have the
right set of permissions so just don't
get discouraged you'll eventually have
the right set of permissions and it's
it's basically this it the similar
structure and all three where you're
just saying I want this service to be
able to read this service I want this
service to be able to write to the
service and kind of just connecting them
all and giving them explicit permissions
and then just being careful if you give
too many permissions see if you can dial
up back it's just a safer way to run it
another way to do is with API keys and
that's what I've been doing for what I'm
touching it externally as well um it's
just exactly what you think it is you
generate an app you can automatically
generate API keys using your
CloudFormation file and then just hand
those API keys out um let's see one nice
thing about AWS they have a tool for
handling these are security called AWS
Cognito it lets you set up user pools
with different permissions and
automatically assign users as they sign
up it also you know uses social social
login and things like that I highly
recommend just letting it handle you at
this
for you which is nice everything in
Azure is a very similar design see they
have a secret manager just like AWS they
have the API keys they have I am and all
that all that jazz
one thing they have is called claims
principle which I did not take in too
much because it only available on that
but if you're done that user you can go
in and and use more of that hopefully
they keep bringing more and more
features to Python so I'll actually use
them let's see so Google does pretty
much the same thing they use a tool they
use I am and then ooofff
and there's also a tool called firebase
that lets you go outside TK through the
social logins and email password which
was really easy and oo auth if you
haven't used it before it's a way of
letting the user log in and agree to the
permissions you asked for so if you used
any app you've probably used OAuth
because it says like oh can I have
permission into your contact so I can
text them and send them ads or something
so it really makes it super easy they're
like copy and paste this code or look
great that's what I exactly what I
wanted this whole time and you tell
generator for you so one question that
comes up often with serverless is
observability how do I know my function
is running when it's not actually
running when I don't use it with
traditional server you can kind of ping
let you know ham still there so just get
those logging tools on you can connect
them to blogging tools you already use
adding century was like super easy so I
definitely recommend that but any other
tools there's a way of like plugging it
in I don't see exactly what I just said
oh and Google is the only one turn on
logging by default so that's really nice
to them and they also had a feature
which I thought was really cool that if
you just hit print in Python it puts it
to the locks and I was like oh I know I
already know how to print fantastic so
we're finally near the end I hope I
didn't talk to you fast at the end I
probably should have had less slides but
it's kind of like this huge you know
monster it's
an epic journey and I hope it has you've
learned something as much as I have I've
come to some conclusions but I don't
want you to take it as like Dogma like
Oh Michelle told me to use Azure I
definitely gotta use Azure they're
always improving all the time my goal
instead is for you to give you a
framework for deciding for yourself like
knowing what questions to ask when
you're deciding which framework to use
so I want to know what is available how
do they connect how fast can I get
started how do I describe infrastructure
how do I test everything how's our CI CD
pipeline can I secure the app and can I
monitor what's going on so kind of the
general for how many did I put here
seven big parts of an app so let's ask
they I was able to answer all these
questions for all these providers they
share some of the same design patterns
in architecture even if they implement
them in different ways
so how decide what to use sort of the
technical questions what language are
using I use Python because the language
I'm most familiar with but for usually a
a sure was the big winner go to your
provider and see how many examples are
in the language you want to use and how
many services support it are they in
beta
do you prefer tried-and-true are you
comfortable with tools being a beta it
sees more risky but then you know this
isn't like a huge project you get more
input on the final product you can
actually talk to the people of these
companies and say hey this isn't working
and please fix it and then let's talk
about angles how do you want to use it
do you work at a company and want to
test the waters with a service
microservice then your answer is what
provider they already use I found when
trying to humans a team to adapt adopt a
new thing it's best if it's only one
thing at a time so you want submit a
pull request of five new features I
don't think you convinced your CTO to
use a new provider and a new
architecture so just keep that in mind
if you're instead looking to just grow
your skills to be more marketable
look at the companies you're interested
in working for and see where they're
using AWS has the biggest market share
so if a company uses a different
provider you're gonna be even more
demand there's just not as many Google
architects and a as your architects is
our AWS and of course if you want to
work for any of those companies use
those tools if you're looking to create
a new business I would contact them
these directly and see it will give you
the most credits because they love your
business and they want to have it they
want you to start with it because if
they give you if they're nice you own
are small you'll be nice to them when
you're big so ask them what they need
and then if you're just looking to have
some fun then I say use Azure because
their development advocates are the most
fun and also because Microsoft is always
the unexpected choice for fun Amazon is
the og of cloud providers and it shows
it has an extensive array of tools and
is used by most the marketplace but in a
fast-moving tech world that can be a
downside the other providers were able
to see how they worked and build on them
better measure has a really interesting
design I love their light trigger and
binding concept and once I realized how
it worked everything kind of fell into
place it also had the easiest quick
start but it's in beta for Python and I
still haven't gotten things entirely to
work because of that so just be careful
if you're using Python
Google uses flasks and its own routing
system which is nice because there's a
toys already familiar with and it should
be if you've already made any restful
api sand python which is nice the error
message weren't helpful the fact that I
actually got a response on my ticket was
a big plus I didn't talk about support a
lot but there's kind of different ways I
did it I tried contacting them AWS and
Azure AWS never responded to me as
you're responding to me weeks later
Google responded to me in 24 hours I
posted on all their message boards no
one responded to me I posted on Twitter
and slack and didn't get a lot of
response either so just keep that in
mind when you're working at Google which
is actually the fastest support it's
very it can be very easy to get
overwhelmed by this I found this project
overwhelming I would say something about
80 hours to do all these projects I
don't want you to have like
fifteen pages of documentation open and
take I'll never understand this you will
for Morgana's talk I found that most of
documentation is detailed and every
single feature but not great on that
user story like there was no good like I
want to create this kind of app what do
I do
so if you want to find a specific flag
on a specific function it's there
hopefully over time more of these user
stories will get written
maybe you'll write them that'd be super
great please do
here are the repos they're all on my
website as well and you just find them
in Michelle and github I'll update them
as I add new features I'll show you some
stuff I need to add to AWS they were
working on before feel free to contact
me about any of them if you have any
questions today I don't know if we have
a ton of time but you can always find me
on Twitter and if you have not gotten
sick of hearing me talk I host a podcast
called from the source weren't interview
people in tech to answer the question of
what tech jobs are really like both the
good and the boring and I should make
this talk shorter thank you very much
thanks to Michelle for this is a great
talk on is obviously very dense then
subject and if you weren't here
yesterday all these presentations are
being recorded so you'll be able to view
this later a week or two later they'll
be available and we do have time for
questions so all I'd ask is Michelle if
you repeat the question
no thanks for the great talk Michelle I
have a question on if you have to
basically I think what I took away from
the talk is that what which server which
cloud provider you choose has a lot to
depend on what you're trying to
accomplish so if you're doing a personal
project without any restrictions by
company which cloud provider would you
kind of start off with given you know
it's like your personal project so it
depends on the language so if you're
using Python I want to do a sure that's
just a little hard right now because on
beta I would say either Google or AWS
Google if like you don't know a lot
about glue providers the fact that
Google actually
my question within 24 hours just was
just really nice so if you're kind of
just starting out so it's just a nice
way and then I can easy win but just
remember that AWS is most of the market
so if you're looking for a job most
people are and you want to do some
infrastructure they'll probably ask you
about AWS but if you know one of them
you kind of learn the other one it's
kind of like blending different
languages once you're proficient on one
you can start to learn the other one but
I really liked the support that Google
provided thank you I just want to thank
Michelle one more time for doing all the
hard work and sharing this with us and
I'd appreciate if you give her a round
of applause
[Applause]